[Music]
back to tick-tock
apparently the moderators were told to
suppress videos from users who appeared
to be too ugly poor or disabled which
was a part of their the company's
efforts to create curate and
aspirational air in the videos that
promote what what does it make sense
there's moderators for the yeah so you
know like that before you feet before
you page for your page that's why they
do a hashtag fyp they cause it feed in
this article they were written by a
boomer boomer read it
boomer right you paged for the on the
page so they're saying that it's an
algorithmic timeline that that's usually
where people go like the first stop on
tick tock is where you go to that page
and then you scroll through tick tocks
and so that's being curated by
moderators and so they were told to not
use anyone that you like with users
within a normal body shape so like
dwarfism or chubby or too thin or those
who have ugly facial looks or facial
deformities they should be removed also
any videos of the the environment that
they're in that looks shabby or
dilapidated and anything that the
environment looks less fancy and
appealing they wanted to live like a
catalog they wanted to look like
Instagram like all night yes but it's
mostly just teenagers in their bedrooms
and stuff it's not like fancy but if you
want fine-ass teenagers like fine ass
like teenagers or something
inappropriate is but I have seen posts
from like plus-sized women who are like
that it ended up on my for you pain how
do they make it there well in the
caption it said this got taken down
three times by tic-tock I'm gonna keep
uploading it until it ends up staying
those margaritas so that I believe it
because like it's only been plus-sized
women that I've seen post that
yeah well Tiktaalik has responded back
and they're like he is crying about you
already reported this before and when
you reported it back then we changed the
policies it's all crying yeah and they
chased it like no uglies on our screen
mm-hmm that's not true though I've been
on ticked are in the for youth page
almost like feet again
it just sounds better for you feed oh
yeah and then so a lot of people were
like what the [ __ ] that's not nice
oh and then also tik-tok said well the
reason why we did this is to prevent
bullying you know inclusive people of
not being inclusive yeah alright guys so
we got a real problem on our hands it is
too many fatties and ugly to get no and
big people keep liking it oh we don't
like that I don't want to see fat people
when I open up the spam so how could we
do this ah see what are you got uh how
big is she first I'm talking huge like
put the camera in the liver role do the
party okay yeah we should spin Bennet
okay but we gotta spin this how can we
spin this Mickey well we can't say we're
banning it cuz it would look like
discrimination absolutely just kind of
oh I know how do we walk off I it we
walk off i we make it quality we'll say
we're its anti-bullying I love it I love
where you're going with this that's
great see this this is why he's here
that's true this is why you see a bully
softer not harder thank you
like it alright that's great let's get
these uglies out uglies bully smarter
not harder
hey the worse oh yes oh you know what
tick tock is is a Chinese platform
Chinese made platform they've owned by a
Beijing based tech company and
apparently they're saying that they have
been trying to separate its
international efforts from its Chinese
home for at least a year but many of
their staff including moderators are
still based in China and so they're
saying that tick tock has already moved
all of the moderating from the big US
content outside of China but they still
rely on their China China based
moderators for other countries why don't
you be Chinese moderators in order to
point out that the Chinese I think
that's it Chinese moderators makes a lot
of sense of why they don't like fat
people on their own seems like they were
like they don't look like us let's get
them out of here
mm-hmm like six of us in that one video
and it's just one person to a Chinese
food no one to say when fatty 16 egg
rolls was enough it was more than enough
I think that's ridiculous I love that
people of all sizes like increase in
colors all have the ability to be
whoever they want to be like on Twitter
because like you give some of the
funniest stuff in the people that you
would least expect quitter is the most
savage [ __ ] Plateau
oh my god I have ever come across too
scary I don't go on there once I was
it's more Sanders in LinkedIn yeah
Oh see some of the linkage oh man
this means I've seen some of the most
creative stuff on Twitter that I've ever
seen in my life like this video right
here I hope the place like he literally
just took emojis and made a graduation I
saw that that is just like come on man
that's so simple and so funny it's so
good but I guarantee he doesn't look
like a supermodel actually I think I
will just page I think he's like for my
Ghana somewhere like you like so right
exactly so well because then tick tock
wouldn't put them on the front page oh
my poor you page come on YouTube and
Instagram probably have the same same
[ __ ] agnostic a lot of ugly people on
YouTube Instagram for them no how come
my whole instagram feed is just hot
[ __ ] people again plus-sized women
who put bikini photos up on Instagram
have gotten their photos taken down but
but the same like we know a lot of
skinny girls who posed way too much yeah
everything but they're pothole and that
never gets taken down so there has been
discrimination on there before I for
sure dude but also but it's also based
on people flagging it too so it's kind
of like the people watching like being
slaggy and I just come into though
another article about tik-tok they were
blocking this other video where there
was this girl where she's trying to
disguise her tick-tock as like a beauty
video where she's like ok guys so in
order to curl your eyelashes and she has
like an eyelash curler she starts
curling them and then she starts talking
about what's happening and she and Jang
where the Chinese government has been
accused of sending at least 1 million
most Muslims and other minorities to
internment camps and she was like no
one's talking about yes it's true but
like she disguised it as like a
beauty thing but it's still got taken
down and then later she why why did I
get take it down from tick-tock you know
why yeah right so that's the whole thing
right now right is that China is using
not only tick-tock but everything that
it owns to try to to distract from its
culpability could be 19 what's going on
in all everyone else so if you could do
this to the to these Muslims you can you
can distract with with tick-tock and by
deleting people's videos what else could
you do in media little [ __ ] hint to
everything else that's going on in the
world you could do quite a bit and they
didn't happen sometimes I don't even
hear distractors like some Chinese
billionaire tycoon guy just disappeared
overnight recently too and all his like
friends were like yeah he was really not
happy with the president of China and he
said some [ __ ] he's that it's not the
first time he's ever said anything he
wrote like essays like in like
publications that was like anti Chinese
government and calm morning the pupu is
like you can't say that in China and
it's banned everywhere because everyone
started to say that she Jane pain who's
the president he looks like looks like
Winnie I see the food so likely then she
got pisses [ __ ] and then now you can't
do anyone who poof means at all the
deleted and and I think I think it was
Facebook or tickets or one of those
started deleting this [ __ ] South Park
did a whole thing about like things that
were banned in China like Winnie the
Pooh's like sad buddy our buddy Bart Oh
Bart Baker no Baker brought Baker Rock
maker he did the wrong voice of Winnie
for the South Park episode rod was on
the South Lawn so a billionaire
disappear that's crazy
over there security you can't be talking
regulars about the president and not
have any type of security think he'll be
ok every there's no reason to not have
security and like an alarm system
security cameras all of it it's the
Chinese government though I wouldn't
[ __ ]
take the board to Duncan instils
brothers misalign it just woke up oh my
god Jason James Bond and once drones
aren't involved and [ __ ] with anybody
yeah you've got a security staff if you
want it's a date fire hell fire missile
I know you're done yeah but like is
there any way that merit somebody
wouldn't be able to like see a missile
blow up a mansion or whatever you say
it's what's no no I'm not saying that
it's just that they'd say all your
mansion caught fire
yeah house fire yeah leaky pipe oh yeah
gas gas leak yep make you control your
car - yeah make it crash into something
oh by the way the CIA that's all public
information CIA has used that [ __ ]
option Oh how about the one where they
can put child pornography on your hard
drive and then arrest you and put you
away for life
oh that's crazy Oh recently I saw this
video I mean this is like way smaller
time but it just popped in my head
where there's this video going viral on
Twitter where this cop planted we look
white like a white package you like it
well no he was like going through the
car no this one the guy is on the lawn
other cops are like like holding him
down he's like I don't have anything I
haven't and then you see the cop like
just slip it out of his like his sleeve
and then the girls recording and she's
like I'm recording it don't worry I'm
recording it and then the cops gets up
he's like you can't be reported and he
starts chasing her and she's running and
then [ __ ] was a cookie dough what no he
was drugs I don't know what kind of
drugs oh I thought that was slang for a
drug cuz I'm so not in the world that
I'm like oh she was like coke mixed with
like black tar heroin like some choco
chips you go to the weed sorum talking
the guys I guess smells like cookie
dough night now it just smells like
we've been 100% it's like I don't I
don't smoke weed at all but like I've
been to dispensaries and they they
really be trying to get now if you smell
this right here it has notes of like
lemon you can also smell like like
that's like resist you like thick wine
smells like we all right look like weed
in an airplane how about this why do you
smell like it has like more of a savory
umami a regular type of a oh yeah I
guess it smells like way more like weed
yeah
smells like armpit like all of them just
smell like weed there's no difference to
me and ever so shut up leave me alone
just somebody might say I was like that
about wine before and now I taste all
that [ __ ] yeah I agree
oh the notes of blackberry I tasted it
yeah we put a swear word you have to be
a wee connoisseurs that's why I can't
smoke it that's why we have to go get
the whatever THC [ __ ] thing because I
can't smoke it because every time I go
there I try to smell it and all this
things and it's pointless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]